[Music]
what dimension are you even in
[Music]
my dad was old enough and lucky enough
to have watched the original series when
it aired and I grew up watching the
reruns with my dad it was always a
special time and they would do these
marathon Twilight zones here in Los
Angeles
on TV and we would sit there and we'd
watch all day long every episode and you
know he had his own personal memories of
him and I created my own personal
memories and always loved them and they
were really seminal for me in terms of
inspiring the kind of work that I wanted
to do genre work and trying to work with
this different theme sort of woven into
it but it's not just the story and how I
got involved what this one was I started
talking to CBS about doing a reimagining
or a reboot of the original series and
then I had a general meeting with Jordan
Peele and Jordan I just started talking
about different things that we loved and
different things there were sort of
inspirations for us growing up and
Twilight Zone was kind of number 1 or 2
on the list for both of us and then we
started talking about what would happen
if we did it together
he was obviously somebody whose work I
admire greatly and it was kind of
perfect he suited to doing that modern
Twilight Zone but he was kind of
intimidated by it at first the same
where I was because it's such a big
mental yeah and then and then we just
started the more we talked about it the
more we felt like we could honor the
original series but do something
ourselves original and unique and update
it and make it feel like a really
genuine and contemporary version of
Twilight Zone that's a question I had
going into it too because I was like
it's a reboot it's a reimagining
are you guys going to remake any classic
episodes or is it more just like about
paying homage and moving forward it's
both every now and then we'll do like a
pretty fun house mirror spin on an
original episode we would never do just
like a karaoke version of an episode but
every now and then we'll do our take on
the original episode we have one in
season one but for the most part its
original stories that have allusions to
the original series that tackle some of
the same social issues of the original
series but are completely new and
different and unique stories as a
society love and easter-egg I noticed a
billion in the show can you talk about
some of the nods you paid to the
original series in this well I don't
ruin anything for fans I would let the
discover themselves trailer I will say
we see the gremlin we see the mystic
sphere yes yes oh good you know you've
definitely been studying doesn't
homework yeah um yeah we wanted this to
be a show that obviously kids or
teenagers or I mean folks really like
sort of in their twenties and thirties
who didn't grow up watching even the
reruns could watch and not necessarily
have to know anything about the original
series but the hope is that it can also
speak to the people that loved the
original series and it can get a new
generation watching the original series
for the first time and discovering what
we all know which is that it's one of
the greatest TV shows in history and so
we have lots of illusions lots of little
references whether they be props lines
sometimes like deep background things in
the production design the art design of
the show and then there's a lot of
issues that we tackle that we feel like
you know we tackle in this slightly
different way but rod was doing in his
own way too before I let you go I gotta
say we have to fight a little bit
because I watched the Dark Phoenix
trailer and I'm like he's really gonna
kill off my girl mystique in the freakin
trailer but that's also made me think
what else is gonna happen at this movie
if that could be in the trailer so I
mean are we gonna lose not everybody's
gonna die I can promise you that that's
not a spoiler but you know that the the
the trailer does indicate what is true
for the movie which is that everyone is
at risk in a way that they haven't been
and all the previous x-men movies and
that they are facing their greatest
threat yet because it's someone that
they all love it's one thing when you're
going up against an arch villain it's
another thing when that arch villain is
like your girlfriend or your daughter or
your best friend or your comrade and so
really the family of the x-men starts to
kind of implode because Jean and Phoenix
starts to lose control and they the
question is like at what point do you
give up on someone that you love even if
they start to kill people that you love
yeah and I'm sure this is a fluid
conversation but the whole Fox Disney
merger like do you know what that means
for the future of our excellent
I don't really to be totally honest I do
know that when we were making this movie
it was well before obviously that the
merger was even in the ether let alone
happening and we approached the movie as
a culmination
the x-men Saga partly because it was now
the fourth movie with the x-men first
class cast and the Dark Phoenix story is
the sort of ultimate x-men story if you
know the comics and if you talk to the
fans and so we really approached it like
it was not the end but sort of a
celebration culmination of 20 years of
making these movies speaking of
celebration just gonna throw this out
there randomly I'm not gonna see what
Star Wars Celebration
may be I love going to those and it's
certainly very involved in that world I
can't speak it out but but definitely I
like going to celebration okay I always
try with you
[Music]